this is jocko podcast number 282
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
a 44 year old lawton man
was among those involved in a three-day
fight recently as part of operation
attleboro
in vietnam he is charles
f whittis who is stationed at fort sill
until
june with the 4th battalion 30th
infantry
and now serves as a platoon sergeant
vietnam
with company a 1st battalion 27th entry
infantry 25th infantry division the
24-year
army veteran's wife florence and
children pat
david sharon gary and wanda
reside in lawton a married daughter
lives in litchfield
minnesota operation attleboro
was not the first time sergeant whittis
has seen action
as he served with the first infantry
division during world war ii
and saw action in north africa sicily
the normandy
invasion france belgium luxembourg
germany
and czechoslovakia
so he had some combat experience he also
served in korea with the intelligence
and reconnaissance platoon of the 19th
infantry regiment 24th
infantry division operation attleboro
has been described as the biggest u.s
action of the vietnam war the 43-day
operation
involved some 25 thousand american
soldiers in the jungles of tanin
province northwest of saigon it cracked
open
on the toughest and oldest of viet cong
strongholds
the campaign ended last saturday with a
claimed bag
of more than 1 100 communist regulars
killed
and nearly 2 400 tons of rice captured
plus hordes of other supplies
i don't think that the fighting out
there was as bad as
in itself as either world war ii or
korea
but this was much more confusing in
korea you at least had lines
over here they were all around you
sergeant widdis said at first i thought
we'd run into a platoon on patrol but
when the fighting continued
i knew he'd run into a much stronger
force
i didn't really have time to think about
what was going on my time was spent
getting wounded out and getting the ammo
to the men
those assaults were the first i'd seen
since korea
they were just the same type that we
called bonsai attacks
our men were outstanding
as good as any i saw in world war ii or
korea
end quote another taking part in the
operation was pfc
john colcerato of lindhurst new jersey
who received his baptism of fire on
those three days
up to that combat action his combat
experience
had been a short sweep during which his
unit received a little sniper fire
i remember the firing was very heavy for
a while
and then it stopped he said i thought it
was over
i'd heard that they hit you and ran but
it was far from over
we were too busy with the wounded to
really think about what was happening
the biggest thing i remembered was the
sun it seemed like i couldn't get
any place where it was cool enough to
think straight
it was worse than i had imagined combat
to be
there was a feeling of helplessness the
bullets were flying around us
and we couldn't see who was shooting
them
i really respect the medics they were
right out there in the middle of it
it was a good feeling to know that if
you get wounded those guys
will come and help you
after it was all over that night i
realized what i went through
you wonder why you are alive
when a lot of other people are gone
and that's a newspaper article from
1966 from out there in lawton
oklahoma and it's talking about
operation attleboro which is mentioned a
few times in the article
the operation is named after attleboro
massachusetts
where the 196th light infantry brigade
had been reactivated out of fort devon's
massachusetts
and the 196th initiated this operation
after they'd only been in country for
about two months
and this i would say this newspaper
article paints the
battle in a very positive picture but it
was a it was a rough paddle
very rough battle the brigade commander
was an inexperienced guy didn't really
have well he was inexperienced
in fighting infantry
didn't really prioritize and execute
lost some control at various points of
the battle of what was happening
and in the end even though as reported
there was
over a thousand enemy killed there was
also um
some significant loss on the american
side 155 men killed and five missing
from the first fourth and 25th infantry
divisions and the 196th
and i i couldn't pin this down i believe
there was
four medals of honor that were awarded
for actions during this battle
and it was the largest largest
series of air mobile operations at that
time
and it was also a baptism of fire as i
mentioned for 196
light infantry out of out of fort devons
massachusetts
and as i was reading about this battle i
started thinking about that idea of
light infantry and
and just doing some reading
doing some research and i came across a
document that i thought
was worth discussing
the document is called proverbs
of the light infantry which out of the
gate you know i'm kind of
already thinking this is this is going
to be good to go
uh it's written by a guy
named major scott r mcmichael he's an
army officer
and not only is he a military guy
obviously being in the army being a
major in the army but
he's also written a bunch historically
speaking
on light infantry specifically he wrote
a book called
a historical perspective on light
infantry
he wrote another book called stumbling
bear soviet military performance in
afghanistan
so he's got you know like i said the
military background he's also got this
historical background which i think
served him well in putting together this
bunch of
proverbs which were published in a
magazine that i was lucky enough to find
so let's check out this document
it starts off history provides many
examples that could help define
contemporary concepts here's an attempt
to define the generic light infantry
and suggest possible training tasks
proverbs
of the light infantry by major scott r
mcmichael
us army so there's an article which i'll
go through quickly
what exactly does army mean by the term
light infantry what is the difference
between light infantry and regular
infantry
is light infantry merely regularly
regular infantry
made light by stripping away its heavy
equipment in vehicles or is it something
quite different
in terms of tactical style attitudes and
utility
and this is what hit me is look when i
when i do these when i when i look at
something when i read something
if i'm thinking it's strict military
information
then i'll save it for when i go and talk
to military troops
however much of the time what you find
is that
military information military knowledge
military proverbs in this place are
something that you can
take and apply to absolutely anything in
life
so when he's talking about light
infantry it sounds super specific
it's a lot more broad these things can
be applied a lot more broadly
back to the book surveying the official
literature on the light division
one is hard put to avoid the conclusion
that our army leadership
is taking the view that light infantry
is nothing more than regular infantry
made light for the purpose for the
overriding purpose of strategic mobility
a number of facts support this
conclusion first the initial design
parameters for the division focused on
restrictions
on size not operational employment
the force designers of the new light
division labored under three basic
parameters
one a 10 000 man personnel ceiling
to a deployed a deployability limit of
500 or less
c141 sorties and three
a requirement for the division to have
nine battalion maneuver elements
so what he's saying there is when they
made this thing
what they what they based it off of is
they wanted to be able to deploy this
thing rapidly
you know only 500 flights of c-140 ones
which is actually a lot of flies
but you know you're going to get 10 000
people deployed in a short amount of
time okay so that's what they're looking
to do
but he he goes on a little bit i'm gonna
skip ahead a little bit
there's more there should be more to it
it shouldn't be just you're a little bit
lighter that shouldn't be the goal of
light infantry there should be some
differences as well
he says certainly the army has not
ignored the peculiar tactical
characteristics of the division it has
after all developed light leaders course
and undertaken a multitude of tests and
studies to determine how to fight the
division
but the hallmark of the division remains
its strategic likeness
not its tactical lightness this is an
imbalance not dismissed lightly and he
literally wrote in here not a pun
so the majors got some got some comedic
chops
for i believe that it shows a lack of
appreciation for the real
meaning of light infantry so he's
arguing here
that it's not just
a a regular infantry unit that's
has less equipment they have a different
attitude and he gets to it here
in contrast and and this is why i think
this applies
because we know one of the things
that's one of the things that's so
fascinating for instance about jiu-jitsu
is it allows someone
who's smaller and weaker to beat someone
that's bigger and stronger
how can you do that tactics techniques
procedures strategy
skills light infantry
well light infantry can beat
heavier infantry how do they do that the
same thing that you use in jiu jitsu
businesses well you're in a business
you've got a competitor that's bigger
than you
and stronger than you and more
capitalized than you are
how can you possibly beat them that's
where i'm going that's what we want to
know right
that's why we love the jiu jitsu right
so that's why we kind of we kind of love
the light infantry too
and we want to learn from the light
infantry just like we learned from jiu
jitsu when we apply it to business we
apply it to life we can learn from the
light infantry so we can take advantage
so i'm sure you're going to go into it
but this so the light infantry
essentially
is um it's for speed right speed
rapid deployment rapid deployability
yeah
but it's like where being the speed is
more important
or is a significant of significant
importance in the situation
so but with that speed comes certain
drawbacks so they have to apply certain
techniques given those drawbacks exactly
how does jeff glover
tap out echo charles yeah can he do it
how does he tap out jocko
can he do it because he's bigger and
stronger can he do it
because he's can apply more force
than i can no he can out maneuver us
yeah he can help maneuver he can move he
can use his lightness and what
else does he have flexibility and then
he has special little tactics techniques
and procedures that he can use
little jeff glover like a little monkey
on your back
so here we get into it in contrast to
the general american use of the term
light infantry as regular infantry made
light there exists another
interpretation mostly european in
context
and origins which is not tied to force
structure or strategic mobility
nearly so rigidly as it is in the united
states
this article sheds light on this
opposing concept
and cites a list of proverbs which
characterizes
operations by what could be referred to
as
classic light infantry there are three
primary characteristics of light
infantry
which distinguish it from regular
one an attitude of self-reliance two
a propensity for improvisation and
flexibility
three a specific common tactical style
so those are the three things that he's
saying that are the
true differentiators the attitude of
self-reliance is probably the most
significant of the three
attributes since the others are founded
on it self-reliance is based on high
levels of self-confidence
discipline trust unit cohesion and a
never-say-die
approach to problems it presupposes the
possession
of highly developed individual skills
not usually found
in the regular infantry soldier
so discipline
trust unit cohesion the never say die
approach to problems which i like
but you know leadership and strategy and
tactics in that book i talked about
that's good
attitude to have i'm never going to quit
but you also
need to have the detachment to take a
look at a problem where you're throwing
all your resources and not winning and
say you know what i'm going to throw my
resources
at this problem in a different way we
don't want to lose the ability to think
we don't want never say die to translate
to
never think of another solution to a
problem that we're facing
light infantry know that no matter what
no matter what the situation they can
make do by turning the situation to
their advantage
love that oh there's there's bad weather
cool watch this we're going to use that
to our advantage
oh there's tough terrain great we're
going to use that to our advantage
classic light infantry almost disdains
logistics believing that is it is
possible
to live in on and off the land and to
use the enemy's supplies and weapons if
necessary
self-reliance transcends unfavorable
circumstances
and finds a way to accomplish the
mission through
innovation imagination and perseverance
disdains logistics we don't even
want support we don't even want a supply
chain
we're going to live off the land
[Music]
the light infantry's attitude of
self-reliance leads directly to a
propensity for flexibility and
improvisation the light infantry cannot
afford a rigid approach to tactical
problems so i love that because now
we're going back on
the fact that we have a a never say die
attitude
guess what we also can't afford a rigid
approach to tactical problems so we got
a good dichotomy that's getting balanced
out now
we were a little nervous at first and
said light infantry seeks to respond
quickly to change
turning its strengths against the
enemy's weaknesses in ways that the
enemy
does not expect yes jiu-jitsu
the light infantry leader improvises to
accomplish his mission by changing his
tactics and organization
whenever necessary
so that's very different from
traditional
military thought right oh we got a
different problem let's just change our
organization change our tactics what we
got to do
old equipment is used in new ways and
new methods are developed to meet a
changing situation
light infantry is light of foot so to
speak and light and quick of
mind as well i wouldn't even see as well
i'd say that's probably the predominant
trait that we want
light of mind quick of mind
amazing how people get entrenched in
their own little ideas
or their own big ideas yes sir
entrenched
can't move the light infantry uses
improvisation and flexibility as a
combat multiplier thereby
frequently achieving a psychological
advantage over an
enemy which may out man and outgun it
i was talking to someone the other day
uh client
and the
i'm hearing him he's trying he's asking
me to help him come up with a strategic
plan
a b c d e f
and he's getting some resistance you
know he's got different parts of the
team pulling them in different
directions
and he's having a hard time making a
decision of like well
we could do this but then if this we
could do that but then i'm worried about
this
so it's a problem
and what i'm sitting there listening to
him
and i'm thinking and i have to play this
mental game with myself
because the way that you don't find an
answer
when you're talking to someone is to
try so hard to understand what their
perspective is
that you become wrapped up in the
problem yourself
so i was kind of doing that i'm thinking
well you know he says well you know this
group is saying that we should do this
and this other group is saying that we
should do that
and i'm starting to weigh those two
groups out and see which ones you know
you know what i'm saying so
i'm starting i'm getting too close to it
yeah so i'm listening so what i have to
do is i have to
actually play this little game with
myself right where i say okay what would
i
actually really do if i was in the
situation
and i said hey
neither one of these groups know what's
going to happen and neither do you
and you right now are trying to make a
rigid plan
about a future that is unknown to you
let's
reassess the plan and come up with one
that revolves around flexibility and
adaptability
not about not around rigidity
problem solved and that's really all it
took
that's really all it took how can we
come up with a more flexible plan
we don't know do you know what's going
to happen tomorrow no okay so we can
come up with a plan but we want a
flexible plan because it
you can plan to go to the beach but we
don't know what the weather's gonna be
yeah it's kind of like the over packing
thing we talked about a long time ago
where
uh refresh my memory you know like
that's why you wind up over packing
because you're like what if we do this
what if we do that what if we do this
what if we go to dinner what if we go
swimming what if we go whatever it's
like bro you don't know if you're
even gonna you don't even have a plan to
go to dinner even though you kind of
know you go to dinner sometimes you know
and then you do that too much
right you're over here over packing yeah
unless you're levison
levison remember that that's the light
traffic
he's had iran he had some light infantry
traveling right there yes sir
and he's got a backpack and eight
dollars he might be
straight up over light infantry
traveling i was thinking about i was
thinking about him
from this perspective you know you do so
much contingency planning
right in the military what if this
happens what if that happens he must
have been looking at contingency plans
like oh
don't worry it'll be good we'll figure
it out yeah and that's the key to that's
one of the keys to
light infantry yeah flexible planning
yeah especially with that approach you
know
so you you go to in our case we'll go to
kauai
you need a certain amount of things that
you need you're going to need like seven
yeah like shorts your surf shorts in
fact you get the hybrid shorts
the surf shorts plus casual okay we're
good yeah i think we have some of those
yeah they do
you know a shirt uh you know a few
shirts or whatever
make sure you have a laundry machine
over there toothbrush one toothbrush
toothpaste you can kind of get
toothpaste there and really a toothbrush
yeah and that's a big part too where you
know kind of like living off the land
and this sounds dumb i know but it's the
same thing
it's the same thing so you ever like go
to like l.a you just count going to
vaughn
off the land i think you did it is the
travel version of living off the land
when you go to a civilized place what
i'm saying it's a stretch you know when
you go to like
la or something and you're like shoot
i'm gonna be there for two days
um you know two two and a half hour
drive or whatever it's like
i better bring enough toothpaste or i
better right you can stop at any store
in l.a
i can make this work
it's the same thing it's exactly the
same thing travel over
the exact same thing never mind hunting
building a bow hunting down and killing
an animal and skinning it never mind
that no no that's too advanced
we're rolling into
[Music]
all right so we're staying flexible yeah
we are prepared to live off the land
if needed if there's a washer dryer
there boom oh yeah you don't gotta bring
that much clothes you see i'm saying
my first deployment i went to guam hell
yeah
and i thought i was going to nam right
so i wasn't i didn't plan for like a
bunch of civilian stuff to be happening
i didn't plan to be
you know down at the beach all day
most days which is what we actually did
on my first deployment
and i think i had maybe two pairs of
shorts and i just wore them
the entire time i would wear one for
like a week because you're just in the
ocean
you're you know you're taking a a fresh
water shower
and you're just totally good to go
living off the land as they say yeah man
that's a
and that's how uh that's how kawaii is
too like you're wearing your
shorts that you're going to the beach in
pretty much the whole time pretty much
yeah so yeah you bring two of those
you're pretty good pretty good you've
got a backup you got background
it's true that's true check see
i knew there was light infantry
application even the echo charles's
existence were there
yeah we're there all right back to the
book
not surprisingly self-reliance
improvisation and flexibility produce a
unique
tactical style as the key features of
which
are surprise stealth shock and
offensiveness
the light infantry always seeks to
retain the initiative
to keep the enemy off balance
that was uh here's a good quote from
dean lisch because i was training with
him the other day and while he was
teaching class
he said okay so the guy on the bottom
across side
what advantages does he have were you
here for this class
oh no but given what you're saying right
now i've
he has said this yeah so he he you know
and everyone kind of throws
actually there's not a lot of guesses
because let's face it when you're on the
bottom
when someone's across side on you you're
not feeling a bunch of advantages at all
okay
so he looked at it with a positive
attitude
and he said no when you're on the bottom
and someone's a cross-eyed on you you
can't fall down
yeah that's a good attitude yes it is
it's a good attitude i thought of
another one i didn't say it to him i'll
have to discuss it with him
it's the the person is going to have to
give space to submit you in most cases
from across side there's going to be an
opportunity
when if people try and submit you if
you'll just hold you you're
you're going to get held yeah but if
they make movement
to advance position or to submit you
they're
the advantage that you have is there's
going to be some space yeah
like i think there's even less space
if if if i'm in dean lister's closed
guard
i feel like i can move less even when
he's going for something
than if he's a cross side that's kind of
how i feel might be particular to my
style or whatever but yeah you can't
fall down when you're already on the
ground that's true
that's a big advantage i guess
off balance the way that a good jiu
jitsu player will attack
your balance that is just that that's
the same thing we have to think about
on the battlefield how can we keep the
enemy off balance
in the business world if the if the
competitors know exactly what we're
going to do
they just plan for it they make a plan
and the more they think they know what
you're going to do
the less flexible their plan is so when
you do something that throws them off
balance
it's going to be good for you light
infantry operates
most frequently at night and uses
terrain at hand
to full advantage light infantry is
terrain oriented
and is able to switch operations from
one type of terrain to another
without paralysis of the mind
paralysis of the mind how often do you
see that
a shift it's it's very it's actually a
specific thing a switch
in terrain a environment and people lock
up
i see it yeah i can see that especially
and this goes back to something they
already said especially when it's a
surprise
if i surprise you with something
yeah that's when brain freeze happens if
you kind of see it coming
you're preparing for it so it's almost
like surprise
has to be utilized to cause people to
freeze up yeah
oh yeah in my opinion moreover
in combat the light infantry is
logistics conscious
but not logistics dependent light
infantry relies on superior tactics
not superior firepower to win the battle
that's jujitsu
short discussion this short discussion
barely
scratches the surface of the issue it
does however
capture the essence of classic light
infantry the proverbs which are listed
here
go into more detail and hopefully
clarify the picture
somewhat further they have been gleaned
from the close
study of several excellent light
infantry forces
in the recent past although many of
these proverbs
apply equally well to regular infantry
as a group they do
a fair job of embodying the nature of
classic light infantry
as distinct from regular infantry in
conclusion
even though many of these proverbs
should be embraced by
all infantry not just light infantry
history
has demonstrated the difficulty of
including
the difficulty of inculcating the light
infantry virtue or style
except in small segments usually elite
elements
of national armies so what he's saying
there is
these are great and they'll work
for regular infantry
but these are these these skills are a
little bit
harder to grow inside of an organization
so chances are even though they're a
good idea to try chances are you're not
going to be as effective
making this happen now i can tell you
that
i think this thing was written decked in
i don't know 40
40 years ago something like that i think
times have changed
i i think you'd find going out and me
actually working with light infantry
units
man they're good so or sorry with
regular infantry units as well
and armored infantry units as well like
i've worked with all of them
and they're all freaking good to go
that's what how you get good when you've
been at war as a nation for
you know a couple decades
the us army particularly has a history
of being tied to its logistics chain and
has relied more on firepower than on
military art fruits victories
some truth to that let us assume that
the new light
infantry divisions should be trained in
the classic light infantry style the
army may find it difficult to do so
since it it is a style with which we are
basically
unfamiliar except for our specialty
forces particularly
the ranger battalions the first step
however is for the army to decide what
it means
by light infantry is it merely light
infantry made light by the absence of
heavy equipment or is it something
more like what has been described here
this is a question which should be
answered quickly
for it has a significant bearing on the
training strategy and leadership of our
new
light divisions so that's kind of his
intro
i think it's a good solid intro i think
it gives us an idea
and it also again the reason i think
this is so
uh so usable is because
we're talking about a smaller weaker
force going up against a bigger stronger
force
this is maneuver warfare this is
indirect attacks that's what this is
that's why it applies yeah
i feel like this applies to more people
especially when you start applying it to
other than
something other than military stuff
where
because it's so feels like it anyway
that so often we find ourselves in a
situation where it's like dang i don't
have like the experience i don't have
the
resources i don't have the you know i'm
not
as big as that guy or whatever and we
feel like we kind of don't have a chance
you know
because they they're just so far ahead
of us in that way so it's like oh no one
has a chance
you know they they're like a monopoly in
whatever way you know yeah
but it's not the case you know it's true
and you know it's interesting from a
business perspective so i i work with
all different industries right
but one day i'll be talking to a client
who is the small
startup you know 400 employees
on the growth pattern they're making
things happen but they still
can't they still have some disadvantages
against the big boys
right and so i'll be talking to them
about okay here's what we need to do you
need to work cause you know you work on
your mobility how can we
outmaneuver the enemy like all those
things the next day or even the next
hour i'll be talking to one of the big
companies
that has all these little elements out
there these small startups that are
trying to snatch business share
what are we gonna do to immobilize those
small so
i actually end up teaching both
insurgency and counter insurgency
depending on the client
and what's good is that i
since i since i i i'm familiar with
how each one of those components needs
to win
so i can help them counter what's going
on
yeah yeah so it boils down to execution
too
it boils down to execution can you
actually do
what i'm talking about yeah because if
you can't come up with a flexible plan
or you can come up with a flexible plan
but you don't have the leadership
to actually make it happen you're not
gonna make it happen
yeah that's so true huh so even like the
like that he talked about the mindset
early on the mindset that we're looking
to change direction we're looking to be
creative like it's quit you know quick
unlike you know let's face it the bigger
i don't know i'm thinking of a company
by the way but if like the bigger the
company is the more it seems like hey
you better have your protocols in place
that we all follow otherwise the thing
can get all unorganized so it's like
they kind of have no choice but to be a
little bit more rigid in that way
rigid bureaucratic
very stable yeah very difficult to
change
so what does that mean that means when
you're a small company you're like oh
you client needs this guess what we can
do that for you can turn around we'll
shift how we do things
for you yeah the big companies uh we
don't actually do that
yeah let me put you on hold on you can
you can we'll you will give you the
system that we use and you can use the
system we use
the small clients like we'll adapt our
system no factor let's do it
shoot it don't get them on customer
service but you go to a big company
customer service they're going to be
outsourcing
reading scripts like all this stuff
because they kind of got in
a big way where it's like hey we need
everyone to give the same quote-unquote
quality customer service like we need
you know you got to know all this stuff
about our big long-standing company
you know to help these people so you
better be educated right
so good example big company
maybe they they know that they're going
to lose out on customer service
because the small company can can adapt
quicker and make adjustments so that
means the big company needs to invest
more in that area
and maybe they need to hire some experts
and maybe they need to
dump some money into uh you know
computer help where i can actually log
into your computer and i can help we're
talking about the software right i can
hel you know no problem mr charles i'll
tell you what if you type in this code
word i'll get into your computer right
now and i can get that fixed for you
right you want to put money so you know
where your weaknesses are
you identify your weaknesses and then
you
fix them and if you're the small guy you
know where the enemy's weaknesses are
the big guy's weaknesses are and you
exploit those
you start making fun of them start
capitalizing on them
which you got to be careful because if i
start if you're the big guy and i start
making fun of your customer service you
could
you're a big guy you'll dump a bunch of
money in customer service all sudden you
start beating me there yeah
so i got to be careful i don't want to
provoke the big guy yeah maybe i just
want to stay under the radar
yeah and and keep take taking customers
from you
and you don't really know why it's
because i respond to every single
customer
service issue you know with a team
that's going to talk directly within
three minutes
that's a very uh
that's very significant concept
staying under the radio radar i think
it's underrated too
because even just as a human being it
feels like
you want the attention you want the
credit you want the
recognition for this you want to win the
award you want them to know you won
or you know even more scary or
counterproductive is you want the enemy
to know that you just
did this yeah and that's more
counterproductive because now you're
giving away
what your position is yeah you're giving
away what you're doing to achieve
victory
and bro that goes deep because even even
if you're not like
because no you know like okay if you
want the enemy to know right
that's like some like hey this is me
against you i got something against you
personally so boom yeah i got you what
kind of a thing right it's like a
challenge almost kind of thing
but even if like just everyday stuff you
know some people for example they'll
make they'll start making a lot of money
or something
and then they'll buy like jewelry or
something like that or something flashy
you know
or you know they maybe they have some
online following or something and then
they want to show their nice cars and
their nice house and they want to do all
this stuff
right just to like show how it's like a
need i guess you know for recognition or
whatever
bruh now what you did is you provoked
the giant now
you made everyone know about their stuff
now this giant whatever that may be i
don't know how that translates but it is
something
whether it be people trying to take
advantage of that people asking you for
stuff
um you know people trying to use your
xyz that you just showed them that you
have
by the way voluntarily voluntarily yeah
because you needed some work
now they're they're gonna try to find a
way to use that for their advantage and
then it's like everybody too
potentially that's the giant there's
your giant right there
you gotta watch out for that you gotta
watch out for your ego getting you to do
things that are stupid
yeah straight up probing the giant or
whatever
like even in uh in iraq in ramadi we
didn't want we tried to we didn't want
the enemy to know what was happening
like why are why are people getting shot
what's happening
you know we know we're like oh yeah
we're snipers we got
teams input no just all of a sudden they
start
losing guys yeah a lot of them
they don't know why now it's fear and i
mean obviously they figured out pretty
quick
check all right so now we get into the
to the
uh proverbs themselves the proverbs of
the light
infantry here we go light infant light
industry operations
there exists a light infantry attitude
which can be described in a few
characteristic words
offensiveness initiative surprise
improvisation and total
self-reliance
there's a part where we could just end
the podcast right now right because if
you take those
were those concepts to the nth degree
you you know what we're talking about
but you won't get the full impact light
forces are undaunted by terrain terrain
is viewed
as an ally a combat multiplier for the
light infantry men light forces are
terrain oriented
very little terrain is impassable to
true light infantrymen now what i
this to me one thing that i was taught
as a young
frog man
when there's bad weather or there's bad
terrain
that means that the enemy has to contend
with it
yeah and they're not going to and we are
yeah
and so terrain oh there's horrible
steep crazy hills cool yeah that means
the enemy's not gonna be on patrol up
there
we will be yeah undaunted
light infantry does its best when it
lives on in
and off the land it must be comfortable
in the bush or in ralph's if your circle
drops in la for two days
uh that you know what how much of that
okay so let's take jiu jitsu
how much of it is jiu jitsu good because
let's face it if you play out like
zombie apocalypse in your head
you kind of think hey when it comes down
to it if i can
beat people in fights look because we
we ran out of bullets you know what i'm
saying like you get to a point where hey
man
it's going to come down to me against
you yeah
so there's a little bit of that that
being able to survive
that you get from jiu jitsu yeah
actually that that's a
a real raw kind of form of it you know
where
and we i think we actually talk about
this i forget i think it was just me we
were just talking
where you can have like a big group of
people
and then they can and you and the group
can be heavily armed
and then and then have a bunch of knives
and then have body armor or whatever
whatever right
just all the tools and all the whatever
there's like you can lose your weapons
you can lose your
knives you can lose your body armor or
forget it or i don't know whatever
but at some point it's very
possible that it's gonna be just like
you said it's me against you
no knives no weapons no whatever yeah
could be that way in about
an hour and a half okay i understand
and then it's like then where are you is
it night and day right you know are you
just business as usual kind of
kind of thing like you know the i don't
know i
it makes me go back to video games but
you know how like you go
there's a game called xanax actually i
feel like i brought this up before where
if you get like
this weapon is this a super spreader oh
yeah that one too yeah on contra when
you get the spreader you're like boom
boom
and you can win oh it's called the
spread i called it the super spreader
because rona
yeah but once you die and lose that
weapon and you go back to just what
you're
issued in the video game which is what
we call the peashooter
bruh you got to be good with that thing
and if you're not you're just going to
game over that's why
be comfortable in the bush
it's true good intelligence is vital to
light infantry intelligence
obtained by the light infantry from
every source
from the national level to the use of
local inhabitants reconnaissance and
patrolling
yeah gathering information absolutely
conventional tactics are no good for
light forces
you know i i would have to dig down and
see what you're actually talking about
when you're talking about conventional
tactics i
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna bless that
one on the spot
i get it right you can't plan sometimes
for instance conventional forces will
plan for a certain number of casualties
for a certain operation like you're just
going to take these couches
you get into light infantry smaller
units that can be a real problem
you can't just accept casualties
for example historically light infantry
operations are mounted at battalion
level and lower light infantry
operations are highly dependent on squad
platoon and company level actions
got it light forces need high quality
communications to coordinate
decentralized efforts into a coherent
whole okay so this this article was
written 40 50 years ago
something like that and
it's just interesting to me
communications of all kinds are
unreliable
radios they're all unreliable in a
combat zone
and if you don't have coordination
measures
in effect that don't rely on radio
communications
you can count on there to be problems
and i'll tell you
even as our as our
as our communication capabilities get
better
when you start talking about fighting
against near-peer
adversaries meaning big giant countries
like ours that have big giant
technological
uh equipment like we have
you can't you get to a point where you
can't use radios because they have
something called df'ing capability have
you ever heard of that direction finding
capability
so if you key up your radio they know
where you are
your radio gives off radio waves and
there are ways
that radi those radio waves can be
detected
and they can pinpoint your location so
so you have to be able to operate
with minimal minimal communications
so i don't like the this this particular
one because it says light forces
need high quality communications to
coordinate decentralized efforts into a
coherent whole actually
i don't i don't like that when i tell
you this is what we're doing this is why
we're doing it i give you the
commander's intent
i want you to be able to go and i don't
need to talk to you again and by the way
you'll see whatever other unit needed to
do something coordinated with you
you're going to know what's happening by
what's happening you're going to see an
explosion you're like oh
late splatoon just started their breach
that means i can go like you you see
what i'm saying yeah
you need to be able to coordinate things
you can't be reliant
on radios you can't
there was probably a year there's
probably a five five year
time period where you where the radios
were good
and the enemy direction finding
capability wasn't quite there yet
but that period's over
due to a general shortage of combat
support light forces must do an
excellent job of combining arms when
they have a chance yes absolutely you
got to be able to work with the other
units that can support you
you got to be able to light infantry
forces must be masters of improvisation
familiar with all kinds of weapons
vehicles landing craft and so forth
yes light infantry forces make use of
whatever is at hand to improve their
combat capability
absolutely
native irregular forces are often used
in support of light infantry
yes what does that mean that means you
have to go build relationships with the
local
populace that's what that means in order
to do that you gotta
know that that's what you need to do
because
18 year old kids with machine guns
aren't
focused on building relationships
they're not they go into a country they
have a machine gun
they have grenades and if that what they
think they're going to do
is hawk grenades and shoot machine guns
so you need to educate them and make
sure that they
understand how the local populace is
going to
play a role in giving you support
light infantry must remain flexible in
mind and action capable of reacting
quick
quickly already talked about flexible
plans flexible mind
when a light infantryman rises from his
sleep he is ready to fight
i like that light infrastructure men
rely on
camouflage why is that because we don't
want to give away our position
we don't want to advertise what we're
doing we don't want to advertise how
we're beating the competition
we want to have camouflage against
heavy enemy forces the light infantry
always
requires a great deal of augmentation
cool
you've gotta you gotta face the reality
that you may not have the resources
that are needed to defeat a
bigger stronger enemy you have to be
able to say that so if you're
you know that's why that's why there's a
lot of industries right now where
you can get help inside your small
business you can get it support
you can get personnel support you can
get engineering support you can get all
this kind of support
and you've got to recognize when you
need to utilize some of that other
support
you might not necessarily want to build
it out had this conversation life was
just telling me this
when we were starting ef online
and you know we started talking about
building this and building that and i
said hey leif
we don't want to become a software
company and he was like
check you know because it's better to
hire someone that does that that's what
they do for you i don't wanna i don't
wanna have a bunch of
software engineers and programmers and
i.t so i don't want to we don't want to
have all that
yeah that's a different business yeah
really we don't want to be an eye
we don't want to be a software company
we want to be a leadership training
company
cool and he was he was like got it yeah
because we had started because it
it's one of those mission creep things
right where you're like you're like what
if we just add this we just build that
and all of a sudden
you got a proprietary system that you
got to maintain and hire more people
we're not looking to do
why we think light infantry and what you
need to do is
use augmentation if needed
light infantry men must be able to climb
crawl swim ski snowshoe repel
stalk run and hide
obviously echo this is written before
snowboarding yes because i know you're
over there thinking
for those of you that don't know echo's
now a snowboarder
isn't it interesting to actually talk
about the fact that you got to have all
these different
ways of getting around by using your own
energy light infantry must be
able marksman proficient in the use and
maintenance of many weapons light forces
rely on pioneer skills at all level
beginning with the squad to properly
exploit terrain
pioneer skills does that mean you have a
ralph's card
no but you better know where everything
is that's what i'm saying otherwise you
get lost these foreign stores
you know can be hostile do you remember
driving around yeah you do
remember no g like gps is just so
it's a given it's given now yeah
together how did you get around before
gps do you remember off the top of your
head
like you're in a new spot or you're
going to a new spot kind of far away
you brought a map no you get a map yeah
well i guess if i was going somewhere
where there wasn't going to be a way to
live off the land and go into a
convenience store and buy a map
i was taking my daughter to coronado
a little while ago and so coronado is
where i worked for
20 whatever years yeah and what
i live now a few miles from coronado
and we get in the car and i you know
start pulling out my daughter's like do
you want to put in the gps
[Music]
are you serious right now and she says
yeah why and i go
it's coronado i worked there for 20
freaking years
and she's like well i didn't i don't
know
but that's but that's her mentality is
when you get in a car and you're going
somewhere you're gps oh yeah huh cause
she's just
she's the way it is yeah huh yeah that's
crazy oh but well because i had the
exact same incident wasn't coronado was
downtown
and i worked downtown for a number of
years and go down there whatever
so i know downtown i know downtown like
back of my hand yeah
and we're going and same thing she puts
it in sarah sir yeah puts it in the or
is like
she puts it in her gps and her phone and
starts rattling off the directions
as if i don't know you know look at this
man of the world doesn't know um you
know how to get to the place we're going
to
downtown my hood yeah whatever
so yeah i don't need that gps but the
thing is sarah's not as young as your
daughter obviously
but it does start to become like a habit
you know
i mean just so happened i knew my way
around i think if i didn't know my way
around see that same thing
automatically style like i don't even
think twice about it
like in back in the day i used to go um
you know to places or whatever and i
remember going in the either the white
pages or the yellow pages or whatever
they'd have the map
in the front of it and then i'd write
down directions
that's it i got lost before two couple
times but it's not not quite as
effective
as yeah yes i wonder what's how much
that skill is just being lost now i'm
sure
it feels like it's gone straight up gone
you can find
one or two guys and and we could be real
negative about that
or we could also be well what skills
have people now
garnered because they don't have to
worry about that skill anymore yeah
i'm not sure the next one the pertinent
ranger standards of land navigation
are a must for light forces
god know where you're going got to know
where you are yeah
light infantry rarely uses roads or
trails what does that mean
how does that apply i'll tell you it
applies you find new ways of doing
things
and just because there's a beaten path
doesn't mean you should necessarily take
it doesn't mean you can't take it
but you should think is there a better
way to get this done
light infantry forces left in combat
theaters for long
inevitably become heavier due to the
acquisition of heavier weapons plus
increased logistics structure what does
that mean keep moving
keep moving the minute you settle down
now you're going to start to now you're
going to start to grow in ways that
aren't necessarily beneficial
light infantry appreciates heavy fire
support when it is available but is not
dependent on it
physical conditioning and mental
strength are absolute musts
across the board light forces
this goes into the next section which is
called the offense
light forces may be deployed at the
operational level of war but they always
fight at the tactical level
light forces think at the tactical level
and okay there's another one i'm like
i gotta press pause on that one i'm not
blessing fully
you okay except for cav i guess caveat
light forces think at the tactical level
but you better
understand the strategic goal you have
to understand why you're doing what
you're doing
otherwise you can't think at the
tactical level
because if i say all right echo we want
to take out that building
and you say cool got it and you get in
there and there's a little bit of
resistance so you
you know blow it up and then i say
actually strategically we're trying to
keep the infrastructure in place here
and you're like oh you might not want to
let me know that so thinking tactical is
cool
it better be nested inside the strategic
goals does your team
where's your team at by the way in your
business
in your company in your family where
where's their head at
do they understand the tactical goals
that you're going for do they understand
are those tactical goals nested
inside what we're trying to do
strategically good question
true light infantry loves the night
light light forces
fight at night and hide during the day
how does it how does that apply i'll
tell you how
you need to understand where you're at
at an advantage
that's what that's saying look night day
whatever we're not
we're not transferring this you know
you're not going to be hey our
you know our construction company is
going to do better at night that's not
what we're saying
what you say is hey there's a there's an
area of construction that we're good at
we're really good at high-end custom
homes or we're really good at
multiple massive track homes that we
just repeat the same
you're going to be find what you're good
at and you're going to exploit that
you're going to start
focusing on that area you're gonna hide
from the areas where you're gonna get
beat
light infantry attacks violently and
suddenly on two or more axes
seeking flanks and rear of the enemy
right we're not going toe-to-toe we're
not this isn't a pugilistic endeavor
where we stand here and punch each other
we maneuver we get to flanks
this is you can see how all this stuff
just fits right into my brain
it just fits right into my brain attacks
are conducted
fiercely and tenaciously against enemy
weaknesses not strength
not the enemy's strengths that's
maneuver warfare maneuver warfare
we maneuver to where the enemy is weak
that's jiu-jitsu
we put my deadlift power
which is my hips and my back against
echo's
curling power which is an arm lock and
despite your
relatively powerful curling capabilities
done compared to my deadlift and the arm
lock
will win
light forces attack stripped for
action so
when you're in the field you can be end
up carrying a lot of equipment when you
go on the attack
they're saying here don't carry that
equipment with you into the attack
what this is what this is is prioritize
and execute
look we carried all this weight in now
we need to focus on the biggest problem
we've got which is doing this assault
take off your gear leave your water
behind not all of it leave a bulk of
your water behind leave your cold
weather gear leave that stuff behind
we're going on an assault we're gonna be
light it's gonna take us an hour and
we're gonna win
that doesn't mean you leave everything
light infantry creates a shock effect by
the suddenness and fierceness of their
attacks
check attacks are closely synchronized
which is fine
again you have to coordinate things
so that perfect synchronicity
is not a requirement for success because
perfect
synchronicity is likely
not going to happen if you don't put
some fudge
in your schedule for the manufacturing
of your new item
the chances that every piece of that
item that you're manufacturing
comes out exactly as desired
and then fits perfectly with the rest of
the pieces that you've manufactured the
chances that happening are very small
so if you put your if you put everything
reliant on perfect synchronization
you're dumb
we don't want to do that
can it are there situations
where you do need to do that sure you're
launching a freaking rocket into space
you know what i mean so you've got nasa
you've got all these people
focused on one thing that that
literally cannot have any issues
so there's all these checks and balances
the whole way through and you have
actually get a
very very very very high probability of
success
however it's still not perfect and if
you try to keep going until you
everything was perfect
you wouldn't ever launch a rocket
because you can't get everything
completely squared away
so if you're not at risk of losing a
500 billion or whatever trillion dollar
rocket
and what you're trying to do is get a
get a
get something to market you need to
not rely on perfect synchronization
things won't be perfectly synchronized
you need to be okay with that if you
have a propensity to be super anal
retentive about every little thing
it's going to be hard for you to be in a
leadership position without letting some
of that go
you have to be like you know it's pretty
close you know there's some people that
cannot say that
yeah there's some people that cannot say
that's pretty good
pretty close that'll work yeah isn't
that one of the main
initial challenges of becoming like uh
what do you call so when you got to
start delegating when you have a
growth situation or whatever like that's
the main one i would say almost
right it's one of the main ones yes yeah
where you can't like
can't let it go i would do this
perfectly cool
but you have 14 other things you need to
focus on yeah yeah get a grip
light infantry always and that is
italicized
in the text when you're when i was an
english major
they call things the text like
are you referring to the text yeah
what's the difference between
the text and the copy uh copies what
they say in the
in um that's more of like a marketing
word
marketing they'll be like hey did you
can you check the copy on this latest
thing
so all those buzzwords so it's like the
purpose of what has been written
that kind of dictates whether you call
it the text or the yeah but the
english you know professors i think it's
an
elevated way of speaking because they
don't say well what do you think of this
book
right which is what a human would say
which is what a person would say
they say why don't you give me some
feedback on on this text
you're like well
right because they're getting paid money
and so they can't just call it a book i
know right
that's way important did you read the
play what did you think of that play
no it's how do was the impact of that
text on youtube
come on yeah it's not even necessary
sometimes
then again i'm sure there's a real a
reason you know
maybe not no you're right you're right
there is a reason and if we where i'm
sure we're going to get
some english professor that's going to
drop the hammer
of grammar on us yeah you know say well
text actually refers to blah blah blah
yeah it's one of those things where it
could be
where you know how like there was a
reason back in the day where the reason
was like significant and you could get
it you could jam it up if you didn't
like disdain or distinguish or whatever
and then but so much has happened since
then and then you know the classic
you know guys or whatever they're like
holding on to it saying like no it is
important and all that stuff's like brad
no
no it's not because i know exactly what
you're talking about still but you know
what i love about this particular case
guess what a text
now means it means i sent you a forward
text
that's my kids text each other yeah
and they they got funny texts my uh
so you know how i don't know my son when
he texts
there's you know how
well i have an iphone and it has an
autocorrect right so it automatically
capitalizes letters
automatically puts periods in that's how
that's that's the
default setting i'm pretty sure of the
phone right
he must have manually goes in there and
removes those so
everything he writes is just no
no corrections no capitalization
and no punctuation of any kind it's just
words it's just
uncapitalized words and then my kids
were telling me
if you put a period if you if you text
me echo and you're like hey
can you make it to dinner tonight and i
write
no period the period's kind of like
aggressive
yeah right i don't know i forget if you
told me that
oh man yeah that's crazy huh how this
whole like we'll say for like a
culture texting culture it takes on this
whole
like these rules and etiquette and all
this stuff and that's crazy it's like if
if something's in all cap well i guess
if it was in all caps it'd be
more of an exclamation rate even i think
all caps is like all cap
all caps is straight up almost like
fighting words right if i'm
all capping you oh yeah it's a where
it's going
but that seems like carry over from even
before text messaging went
that all caps is like an exclamation
yeah that was your jam in the beginning
all caps
what what did i all get when you started
texting oh like when i started texting
you
yeah well when you didn't text everyone
like that it was just me
[Music]
like you just thought that that was just
more dope well that's funny you know
what's funny is i write in all caps
you know one of those people that writes
in all caps yeah so i guess for me it
would just look normal
yep yeah that makes sense yeah you know
how like some people don't write it and
i used to do this i went through a phase
all caps but the capitals were just a
little bit bigger physically
yeah yeah i will do that depending on
the scenario
and i'll give you an example when i
write
the path that t is a little bit bigger
and the p is a little bit bigger gotcha
because there's
we're acknowledging the capitalization
actually now i think about it you and i
are
very very uh
aware of capitalization of letters
in texting yeah oh yeah they tell a
story they tell a story
sure means something yeah so and then
there's a
difference between font and typeface
i'm unfamiliar i don't know what it is
so you brought up something you have no
no well you're talking about text like
okay so text back in the days like the
text
and now it morphed probably a couple of
times into different things and then now
so you tell me the difference between
font and typeface yeah that's another
example of like these things that might
have had a difference
at some point but i don't know what it
is like font
like what is font you don't know what
font is i think i do
okay font is just the letters that are
used
to it's the it's the design of the
letters
the actual design of the letter yeah and
then typeface that's what
apparently typeface is the design of the
letters
i don't know if there's any difference
between these two yeah man so typeface
is the elevated expression i think
i think so jack all right back to this
italicized word
light infantry always relies
on surprise achieved through stealth
deception silence and maneuver on foot
i just wrote a question mark next it's
like always always
we want to be careful about saying
always
but i wanted to reflect the text here
itself light infantry always seeks to
retain the initiative now that one the
always
which in this case isn't italicized i
agree with
do you ever want to give up the
initiative no you don't yeah you always
want to maintain the initiative
i i'm scrambling my brain trying to
think of a situation where ah you know
what i don't think i want the initiative
right now i can't think of one
i can't think of one
light forces practice rigorous fire
discipline
but when necessary they deliver intense
fires on short duration to overwhelm
the enemy jack light infantry turns the
enemy's weapons against him
awesome which is and what's awesome
about that is
when you've got you got a competitor
that is utilizing something
they're utilizing something they're
utilizing uh
some piece of marketing they're
utilizing some attack on your clients
they're utilizing something
you can't just say oh no that piece of
marketing really hurts us no you need to
look at that say how can we turn that
piece of marketing against them
light infantry forces conduct relentless
pursuit of enemy light forces and
irregular forces to destroy them
in detail
relentless pursuit of enemy light forces
light infantry offensive operations are
characterized by a high degree of
decentralization
yes which is contrary to saying i better
have
radio to coordinate every single
movement with you that's centralized
light infantry patrols relentlessly and
aggressively ambushes the enemy light
infantry
sometimes double times into battle think
about that
you're like hey we're running we're
running
that's an interesting thing i'm
concerned
i'm a little bit concerned if i have to
run to get to the battle i'm a little
bit concerned about what i'm doing
because i'm running i feel like i'm late
and if i have to run to battle i feel
like i'm late
yeah it seems like that's like a flex
move
as well concur yeah yeah it's sort of
like
we'll run yeah yeah i'm not sure if
that's the smartest thing
i'm running that means i'm late and now
i'm tired when i show up yeah a little
bit more
i mean i'm not saying you can't function
i'm saying you're a little more tired
than you would have been
do we get a cool flex right yeah do we
get to say look we'll run
yeah yeah we'll run maybe like because
it could have been
it could be i guess under certain
circumstances be like a psychological
warfare situation
because in football that's how it was
where it's like hustle off the field
hustle on the field right yeah when you
think about okay there might be a time
saving element to that for sure
but bruh if i'm really not hustling on
and off the field i got more energy for
the play
yeah i'll tell you what when you run
when when like you see
kids wrestling yeah and one kid runs
like they go out of bounds one kid runs
back runs back
neat you know toe on the line ready yeah
and the other kids 100
psychological warfare yeah psychological
warfare
maybe that's why they're saying that
maybe i think you're right i think it
might be in the parlance of our time
a little flex
light infantry tracks listens locates
cuts off raids
and ambushes the enemy isn't that weird
to think about
when you're in you when you're competing
against someone
you actually should think you should be
tracking listening locating
cut off raiding and ambushing them
think about how the thing that i like
about that is you're focused on them the
thing i don't like about it is you're
focused on that
right there's a little dichotomy there
we can't be focused so much on what the
other guy's doing
we need to be doing something
the enemy never knows where the light
infantry is or
when he will attack jack don't give away
your position for the 50 millionth
time i'm not gonna
st when when echo has a different
viewpoint than me i don't start off by
telling him
my viewpoint and explaining why my
viewpoint is better
i don't i actually ask more questions
about your viewpoint and try and
understand your viewpoint and get your
viewpoint till i actually know exactly
where it is
before i reveal my position
standing operating procedures are used
widely by
light forces for quick silent action
yes standard operating procedures
for silent action that means you don't
have to talk we know what's going to
happen
next one rehearsals training
pre-combat briefings and sharing of
information
to the lowest levels are more common
among
light forces this is the cornerstone of
decentralized command
rehearsals training pre-combat briefings
all that stuff
the infiltration of large units of light
infantry is possible
in close terrain and is necessary for
success in major operations under these
conditions
light forces infiltrate to attack the
rear to establish blocking positions and
to create obstacles in the path of a
retreating enemy
yeah check
what that means is we're we're moving
into good positions and we're doing it
in a clandestine manner so the enemy
doesn't know that what we're doing
and the last one for offense is
hand-to-hand combat is a required skill
for the light infantry affirmative
man the the propagation of hand-to-hand
combat right now
in the last since the ufc started is
insane yeah
it's insane yeah yep
it is i mean even in
that community it's it's insane not to
mention like
when you go when you explore the
spectrum of the guy who doesn't know
anything versus the guys
the guys or guy who knows a lot
even within the people of who knows
it's so much like variety so it's so
vast you know
it is it is a insane
evolution in since 1993.
it's crazy the evolution since 1993.
since the ultimate fighting championship
yeah the
evolution of combat sports is almost
incomprehensible
yeah because before then it's kind of
like people didn't really have a valid
found or a
stable we'll say or reliable foundation
of fighting
and then kind of jujitsu kind of
essentially provided that yeah and
everyone started learning it so what
does it look like this is kind of the
answer the que the answer to this
question is what you're talking about
like what does it look like when
everyone knows the foundation imagine
what you can build on it you know
yeah and i guess there's other things if
you look at basketball
right i mean basketball now
is different than it was in 1954.
um right it's a different game i mean
we're talking
it's a different game but i think that's
less
obviously i think mixed martial arts is
might be the most but
skateboarding you've seen what a kid
will do on skateboards right now
yeah it's crazy it's mind-boggling yeah
surfing
i mean surfing is nuts yeah it's
nuts what guys are doing from a
technical level
from a technical blasting airs like what
but not only that blasting 360
ollie airs where they're not even
they're not touching their board but
they're going up and doing a 360 in the
air
and landing it if you brought an old
school surfer from
1962 yeah and you if you were to bring
it if you were to bring a 1962 surfer
and say hey if you go back to 1962 and
said
do you think that a surfer will be able
to launch
off the wave into the air turn 360
degrees without touching his board and
land
does that sound possible
do you know what i mean does that sound
does that actually sound possible
yeah it doesn't re it's kind of hard to
it's kind of hard to comprehend that
that could be an actual thing
yeah you know they probably wait what do
you mean not touch the boards meaning
not grab that board
they didn't even understand grabbing the
board like you wouldn't probably had to
say that part
yeah like how are you going to get a
board out of the water first of all
their board weighs 42 pounds
made of redwood
makes it hard so there's these like you
said there's a foundation once this
foundation gets created you get to build
on it
and what's that's what's so crazy i've
been talking about this on the debrief a
little bit i've been talking about ef
online
leadership there's a base there but
people just ignore it
yeah people think they don't understand
that leadership is a skill
just like just like surfing just like
skateboarding
just like playing basketball it's a
skill
and if you learn then you if you
pick up a book and you read you'll learn
about it and you go oh i can use these
moves
yeah and people don't do that people
people don't understand
why it's very difficult for people to
understand that leadership is a skill
even though they go that guy's a great
leader they think that that person was
just born that way
they don't think what are they actually
doing
i mean when i when i was running the
training and i got to
watch that's what made it so obvious i'm
like oh that guy's not doing what that
other guy did
and that's why they're falling apart
right now got it
check next section is called
the defense light forces can defend but
they are more suited
to the offense defense can immobilize
the light infantry consume too much
ammunition and develop
rigidity of mind these are the dangers
of the defense for light inventory
so you know we're not feeling like we're
we're gonna focus on that
light forces must be able to disappear
into the ground rapidly for defense
light infantry men must be good diggers
and fast
light infantry men must be masters of
fortifications
that seems like we're focusing a lot to
become a master of fortification if
that's not something we really want to
be doing
light forces defend on the reverse slope
i like that one because that's using the
terrain to defend
spoiling attacks are a frequent tactic
of light forces
normally light forces are ill-armed to
defend
against armored vehicles even in close
terrain
this is a very important one why because
it is acknowledging one of our
weaknesses
it's acknowledging one of our weaknesses
so
here we are we have this tough mentality
what is it the never say die mentality
we adapt we overcome and we have that
mindset
and we're in a light infantry platoon
and we're out there and all of a sudden
we see armored vehicles coming
and we go you know what adapt to
overcome we can we can do this
and what this is saying is actually no
there's actually no we are ill-armed so
now we see
armored vehicles coming and we say you
know what hey we need to bag out of here
or we need to get in a
serious defensive position or we need to
hide so we don't get seen
so as a leader you need to recognize
what your weaknesses are and then you
need to actually explain those to the
team hey this is not a fight we want to
get into
hey this other this other manufacturer
wants to go toe-to-toe to us
on making this highly regulated item
we are not good at making highly
regulated items
we don't want to get in that fight now
everybody knows that hey you want to
spend a bunch of money on a bunch of
equipment that costs a lot
and then you get scrutinized over the
production that you're making that's not
what the game we're in you go ahead and
have that game
so you need to understand what your
weaknesses are and you need to propagate
those to the team
light infantry counter attacks
immediately to
retake lost key terrain or to hit the
enemy's rear or flank while he is
attacking
this is what i like about this is this
is a mindset
this is a standard operating procedure
when we get attacked
if we start to lose if we lose rain just
everybody know that we're coming back
we're going to immediately re-attack
that's what we're doing
the light infantryman is invisible and
silent in the defense by day or by night
good way to do defense
not be seen
logistical support true light infantry
is not tied to a supply line light
infantryman
disdain logistics that's so strong
that's so strong
as an important planning factor they can
always
quote make do
disdain's a strong word mm-hmm
it's a strong word yeah in a way doesn't
that kind of
makes it seem like you're painting
yourself in a corner
you know we're anti this almost yeah
yeah and i get it
i get it because it's a because
logistics becomes mission creep meaning
hey look we just you know what we're
going to need water
and we're going to need some we need
water we're going to need water buffalos
you know water buffalo big tanks of
water we need water buffalos
and that means we're going to need
vehicles to till the water buffalos and
that means we need fuel for those
vehicles
and that means we need the maintenance
crew for those vehicles and that means
we're going to need to feed the
maintenance crew you see where this is
going
right so that's why i think we need to
be careful when we
open the door to large logistics because
once we open the door
the freaking party gets crashed and now
all of a sudden we got
you know the cops getting called yeah
so we've got to be careful on that in
that regard
light forces can operate separated from
their lines of communications
by depending on enemy and indigenous
supplies cool light infantry men can
live off the land like echo charles can
i can't wait i can't wait to see the
comments on this one
bro we could do some really funny stuff
with you uh you know
lost in l.a what's he going to do
okay motel eight this looks like this
looks like i think i found i think i
found
i think i found the location for tonight
light forces make maximum use of the
indigenous population for
bearers handlers sorters loaders and so
forth
look this goes back to us earlier
forming relationship with the local
populace
you need to make sure you emphasize that
with the team
otherwise what do you have you have
young men with machine guns and grenades
and that's what they
joined the military to do in most cases
so some people came in with more
idealistic
visions than that which is great god
bless them
but a lot of 18 year old young men
that joined the military didn't join for
those idealistic reasons
so if we don't get them on board with
the
treating the indigenous population with
respect and explaining
how that indigenous population can help
us succeed in our mission and explain
that we are actually there to support
the indigenous population if we don't do
those things as leaders we're going to
end up screwing things up
light infantry frequently resupplies at
night the use of helicopters amphibious
craft and like craft is vital to the
resupplies
of light infantry improvisation is a
constant feature of light infantry
logistics
i'll say this about improvisation
you can train for improvisation
and the way you train people to
improvise is by making them improvise
that that's what you do you can't and
what makes it hard is
training by its nature is a structured
thing right okay i'm gonna set up some
training for you echo charles here's
what we're going to do
you're going to start in the mount
you're going to go for arm lock you're
going to start here
right so there's a structure to it and
we can go through that structure and i
told you what move you're going to do
and you're going to drill that move
so what i need to do is put you in
situations where there is no move
yeah hey get on your back put your left
leg
over your right elbow and your partner
is going to go and grab your
other ankle ready go you have to
improvise to get out of there
you can actually start to learn to
improvise better
so we need to do that when we train
subordinate leadership when we train our
teams we need to put them in situations
that they
actually have to improvise because
there's methodologies
and thought processes that fall into
better
improvisation improvisation if you never
think about it
and you throw your team into such a
situation and guess what you throw your
team into any real situation
they're going to have to improvise that
plan is not going to be perfect
and if you don't train them to improvise
they're not going to be able to do it
technology next section weapons used by
light forces must not
impose a logistical burden
cool if equipment cannot be manpacked or
mule slash donkey pack the light
infantry generally has little use for it
cool we're trying to stay late light the
helicopter is
almost revolutionary in its effects on
light force mobility and logistical
support
check the delivery of the light
infantryman into the area of operations
has changed over time but actions on the
ground have changed little check
historically advantages
in technology have not been the deciding
factor
in light infantry operations this is
important
so we can't just rely on the fancy new
equipment that we've got
obviously that's not that's not going to
make the difference
not it's not going to make the critical
difference it might have a difference it
might make an impact
but historically technology is not going
to be the deciding factor
next section is called political arena
political action is often needed to
support the light infantry operations
cool you know what that means play the
game gotta play the game
light infantry profits from a
psychological
operations edge and must be prepared
prepared to use
this advantage
all kinds of psychological things all
these the shock
that we're talking about the surprise
that we're talking about
those things are a psychological
advantage
and we need to be able to exploit those
psychological advantages
utilize them
cooperation between a light infantry
security force and the local police and
intelligence structure is essential to
success
does that mean build relationships
the hearts and minds role
in low-intensity conflict is one to
which the light
infantry normally is very sensitive
i would say that the light inventory
should be very sensitive to it
but i also think if we as leaders don't
explain to the team the importance of
the
quote hearts and minds then we will not
have them
as sensitive as they should be
i don't think there's a predisposed
mindset that leans towards people that
join the military thinking hearts and
minds
i think you have to account for the fact
that there's a decent chance they're not
thinking about the hearts and minds
they're thinking about other stuff
the last section is leadership
light infantry leaders are generally of
higher quality than conventional
infantry leaders
i don't agree with that i give that one
the down vote
i worked with conventional infantry
leaders
and they're freaking awesome i've worked
with light infantry leaders and they're
also awesome
i don't think they're generally of a
higher quality
light infantry leader traits are
imagination
isn't that funny the first one
the next one flexibility
the next one heartiness the next one
endurance
confidence improvisation discipline
technical expert expertise perseverance
and so forth it's kind of weird to say
and so forth
because you listed one two three four
five six seven
eight nine ten it's like
more
yeah but imagination and flexibility
that is not what people think of when
they think of military leaders right
they don't think of imagination and
flexibility
they actually think of the opposite
rigidity yeah kind of you say that too
right
where they were or actually might have
been another book where creativity
was one of the you know attributes of
the leader or whatever
and you wouldn't really think that you
wouldn't think creativity it's more like
i don't know
maybe the first thing that comes to mind
maybe for a normal person would be
i don't know authority or yeah you know
something a little bit more discipline
yeah right and i talk about discipline
all the time but discipline's only good
if it's
complemented by imagination and
flexibility
light leaders lead from the front
consequently they suffer a higher ratio
of casualties than normal
i don't think this is something that
we're super
trying to make a proverb right right
i get lead from the front absolutely
but are we are we actually leading from
the front to a point
where we're a higher level of casualty
as a leader
i'm not gonna i'm gonna say if i'm
talking to my leaders i'm going to say
listen
you lead from the front and you also
position yourself to where you can
continue to lead without becoming a
casualty
leadership is the most important thing
on the battlefield
if we're losing leaders we are losing
the most important thing on the
battlefield
i get it i get the i get the attitude
but we have to make sure we're smart
about it
junior officers and non-commissioned
officers must possess skills above
and beyond those of regular infantry
these skills include demolitions
artillery calls for fire
the use of close air support and
familiarity with foreign weapons and
foreign languages
fair enough
that comes down to all those things all
those things are just training
so when you're in light infantry units
you should have the opportunity for
more training you can get some of these
skills
teamwork and confidence in each other
are vital to light infantry operations
that is a huge piece of teamwork you
know i call this
trust as opposed to confidential
confidence in each other
that's what bonds a team together i
trust you
you trust me you trust that i'll be
there if you need me i trusted you'll be
there if i need you
and if i can trust that you're gonna be
there if i need you i'm more apt to
go out and make something happen because
i know you got my back
here's a good one courage without
teamwork is of little value
makes sense they didn't say it's of no
value but if i don't have some teamwork
backing me up when
when i do something courageous
not what we're looking for we need
teamwork
morale esprit and spiritual power
are of high value to light infantry
operations
what is a spree esprit de corps it's
like it's like the bond
the bond that we have so
there's not much clarification on
spiritual power
i'm going to go out on a limb and say
that
the team has to believe in what they're
doing
if you're going to be successful if the
team doesn't believe in what they're
doing
it's going to be a problem because we
are not willing to make sacrifices for
things we don't believe in
light infantry men usually usually
leave no casualties on the battlefield i
like that
it could be a little bit stronger than
usually
almost never right and that's different
from the
army saying of leave no man behind and
actually that's all services say that
and that's always the goal
but you also have to make a call
sometimes
and that might be hey we need to we need
to back off right now we need to come
back and re-attack this position later
because right now if we keep going to
try and recover this individual
we're all gonna die
light infantrymen look to their leaders
for a clear
voice for clear voice instructions and
thrive
on the motivation of visually observing
their leaders in action
cool necessary sometimes
clear voice instructions absolutely
sometimes the team actually has to see
what you're doing
and they will take action based on your
performance
they will be inspired and motivated by
saying looks like we're going
and the last one a light infantry leader
can do
everything a soldier can do
and more
so a light infantry leader can do
everything a soldier can do and more
now listen on that one you you're not
going to be able to do a hundred percent
of what your frontline troops can do
and you definitely might not be able you
you certainly might not be able to do
more
right you sniper's going to be better at
shooting than you the radio man is going
to know more about the radio than you
the point man is going to understand the
route better than you do
so that's a little bit
not sure i agree with that you should be
able to know how to do it you know how
to do all those things but you're not
going to be the expert
but you should absolutely do more
if you're in a leadership position you
should do more more work
more effort more sweat more toil
and grind and more exertion because you
work for them
and that's what a leader does
so there you go that's the document
short
sweet proverb proverbs of the light
infantry
good things to think about applies to
many aspects of life
you disagreed with a few things from
there which is
the amount that you disagreed with is
actually pretty small when you consider
this was written 50 something years ago
like that that's
that's pretty impressive uh staying
power as far as all those concepts go
yep and i don't know if we'll ever hear
from major scott r
mcmichael us army but if we do i'm sure
he could clarify some of these and
explain them in a different tone or
different different aspects or
perspective that i don't understand
also you know the time that it's written
i think it was written in
something 1985 maybe so my
guess is as a major he probably wasn't
he
likely wasn't in vietnam unless he was
an enlisted guy in vietnam just doing
the timeline
so maybe bouncing these things off the
wars in iraq and afghanistan would
actually i i think if we discussed them
i think we would come to some kind of
resolution on on some of these you know
maybe that i didn't understand it
correctly
or i didn't see what the perspective
that he was talking about
so you know and he might also be like
yeah you know what i
i didn't fully underst i didn't fully
calculate that aspect of it
yeah so but yeah i mean the vast
majority of them are very
i'm in total agreement with yeah yeah a
lot of times when those
when the language is that of always and
never
so that tends to make you at the very
least
feel like okay there are no real
exceptions to the
to that and then as time goes on
you can start to see the exceptions and
then
you know one exception can can kind of
open the floodgates for others you know
and you're like oh wait we're seeing
this exception kind of often oh shoot we
should maybe reevaluate or update that
always just be like often often or
you know tends not to or something like
this you know
gotta be careful with always never gotta
think so too
all right well speaking of doing more
it seems like we should do more more
work more effort more toil
yeah you said something really
interesting right there at the end it
says you work for them
yeah it's not as intuitive as one might
think when you're
in the position you know a leader seems
like they work for you
if you don't have that intuition you
need to write that on your
you know on the cover of your notebook
yeah
so i have kids and that's another one
right where
it's kind of like it's almost like it's
not and i don't want to say intuitive
because intuitive is the wrong word it's
more like on the surface
like on the surface the kids got to
listen to you you know
um but no like you're the one who
you're essentially working for them 100
to
get them up to speed you know all this
stuff yep
i don't know it's weird now there comes
a point when they they're going to be
working for you doing them
dishes we're cleaning the kitchen
pulling weeds right
so yeah it's gonna come i think about
that too and i'm not
ignoring the benefits of the kids doing
the dishes
instead of me now i'm not ignoring the
benefits of that
but that's not why you teach your kids
to do the dishes
so they can do them for you you know
that's not the primary reason
it's not the primary it's not the
primary well it may be the primary
reason but it's not the most important
reason
okay my emphasis on the word might i
love that
so like i never like i always feel bad
so let's say okay
say one of my kids has a chore this is
real by the way so one of my kids has a
has a list of chores one i've noticed
that a lot of your hypothetic
hypothetical situations are just real
yes you give a lot of let's say there's
a by the way this is real
okay so let's just call it what it is
but there's a reason i do that only
because um i don't need you asking all
these very specific questions
necessarily not necessarily you but
other people ask me these specific
questions and then now
you're going to rat yourself out yeah
well there might be that too
but i i usually am looking for the
answer that applies to more than just me
and my god you're trying to broaden the
expanse of your question i'm trying to
check so i always appreciate it if
let's say the chores are to one of the
chores is to um
load the dishwasher okay put all the
dirt dishes in the dishwasher
but let's say this child didn't eat
dinner with us
they went out with their friends for
dinner and they came home they got do
their chores every night
meanwhile they got to load the
dishwasher all our dishes all the people
you know
it doesn't seem right it just on the
surface it just seems like oh that's
kind of wrong you know
it doesn't seem right to who me oh
making them do that
okay like it's like what are you my
servant now you got to clean up my mess
you didn't even participate you know
it's like it kind of feels that way for
me
echo charles the merciful
but there's a bigger picture than that
yeah where
his job is that for a reason it's not to
clean up after me
it's to teach him that in life like
these things have to be
right like things that you can do you
know
to function so it goes beyond that but
you got so you got to suck it up you
know
yeah yeah but also you need to explain
why
right yeah you need to explain why yeah
and if you explain the why
then they go yeah you know what that
makes sense yeah you can't say cuz i
told you to
you can't say cause i'm the dad you need
to say well here's what's going on
yeah boom i ask them what do you call it
yeah i think it's this is a technique in
sales where you ask them like
questions with only one answer you know
like or
it's basically this like if you say why
can i eat this cupcake or whatever
and i'll be like hey you know cupcakes
aren't good for you right and usually
that just goes right over their head
like's not good for me really because it
seems really good right now
you know as far as i'm concerned so i'm
like okay if this cupcake makes you less
healthy
less the healthy of a person and one of
my jobs on my many
is to look out for you your well-being
and your health
and i allow you to eat this cupcake
would i be being a good dad
they can never say yes sometimes they'll
say yes as a joke but they understand
but they know what's up you know
putting the cupcake down yep explaining
why i'm doing what i'm doing
or they're just quickly biting off the
frosting
what is frosting anyways uh i think
sugar butter
um a lot of butter and sugar and then
there's like
i don't know some vanilla maybe some
cream or something it takes most i would
say
70 percent of the cakes i've eaten in my
life
were only the the cake itself not good
but the frost difference
when you were when i was a little kid
right yeah yeah i wanted to get that
corner piece that was had frosting on
four sides
yeah i got you right were you in that
game or were you taking a middle piece
that had one side of frosting yeah so
oddly
in when i was a kid yes but as i grew up
it's probably just a maturity thing
really you know you know yeah like less
less frosting you didn't mature out of
that
mature out of that yeah in fact i said i
you know i won't want to eat the cake
yeah because that's we know that's just
weakness right yeah but the frosting
that's where sometimes you're like you
know what i don't even need to eat the
pizza cake
but maybe a little knife snatch
full of freaking frosting which i don't
even know what it was until you just
told me
yeah well i understand so there you go
it makes sense
as opposed to say the brownies where you
want the middle piece of the brownie
because that's the softer one
i like the brownie that's a little bit
um like the hardened part you know
around
so you like the edges yeah i guess it
depends on when you're a kid like we're
not i'm just this is all just
when i was a kid you know you're just in
the game right you're just
you're tracking sugar like a little
addict yeah i mean i'm not going pete
robert's level did you hear what
yeah when pete roberts was talking about
having damn
sugar cubes hidden in a pencil holder
hidden in his room
yeah that's going hard he's going hard
for sure like that's
that's some weird crazy stuff yeah
dude that the guy looks like he gets a
look on his face when it comes to sweets
and stuff look i got a sweet tooth sure
whatever man
he starts losing his mind bro yeah so
maybe oh that's right that's where we
had that
he wasn't on the podcast it was we were
up in up in uh montana
and he was started going all sugar crazy
on me started getting the wild eyes
started getting crazy eyes bro talking
about sugar
yeah yeah that's why he's a good test
for jocko fuel
because he's got a sweet a legit like
certified
lifelong sweet tooth yeah we're talking
a crackhead
that's got uh sugar cubes yep and he
gets a weird
twinkle in his eye when he starts
talking about eating sugar cubes he's a
good test for jacqueline's food because
he's not in here going
well you know it tastes pretty good like
he will straight reject
something if it doesn't if it doesn't
have that
sweet little kicker it's true he's not
down for the cause pete roberts oh yeah
and you get a health person who's down
always down for the
you know plain chicken breasts and
broccoli and all this stuff that guy
who's like down for that kind of stuff
and then he's going to taste some
you know some you know peanut butter
chocolate
milk or whatever and the thing is not
where it needs to be
sweetness flavor wise he's going to be
like oh yeah man that's all the chicken
is the chicken breast broccoli guy he's
like whoa man this is amazing might be a
little too sweet
pete roberts like you know if you don't
if you don't knock it out of the park
with pete
you know he's like whatever you know
he's over there freaking crawling around
looking for sugar cubes on the ground
he's doing great speaking of uh jocko
what do we got
yeah so yeah forget about the cupcakes
and all this stuff or whatever
you know if if we know that eating
cupcakes
sugar butter frosting brownies
sugar cubes if we know that that's bad
for us makes us less
less healthy and we have to be more
healthy
to be more capable to help the people
that we work for
jack yet we still eat this stuff are we
being a good
leader good leader good dad good mom
good parent good friend good brother
good sister
good compatriot good human being good
sister yes there's a freaking no dude
negative answer is freaking negative and
i get it things taste good but guess
what
good news i got good news across the
board okay first off before we get to
the too good of the news the great news
leave some guidelines okay we want to be
working out we want to stay healthy we
want to stay capable
we want to stay mentally and physically
in the game we'll see we're going to
stay on this path we're all on
all right so you might need some
supplementation i'll help you big time
chocolate supplement if you're going
hard i'm gonna say you're gonna need
supplementation
yeah if you're going hard you're gonna
need supplementation if you're pushing
hard you're gonna need supplements yep
and we got a bunch so
let's start with the physical and
cognitive discipline
it's the name discipline many modes get
the energy drink
home ready to drink cans you know which
is cool i guess
the capsules and the powder called
discipline so the energy drink cans
they're available in multiple places
wawa east coast east coast jackalful.com
online
vitamin shop is that everywhere
yep worldwide shop boom there you go
only in america but
yeah support multiple options as far as
where to get it this is just energy
drink cans
uh vitamin chop has everything else as
well that we're about to talk
talk about okay so what are those things
other supplementation joint warfare
joint warfare and super krill oil this
is for your joints and some general
health stuff in there as well
um that'll keep you in the game big time
especially on the physical
front also vitamin d3 in cold war
free immunity stay in the game don't
have to worry about getting sick anymore
that's the thing you start over training
not sleeping enough all this stuff
breath sickness will come and get you
take you out for a little while if you
just let that happen are you being a
good leader
are you no that's good
you're letting down everybody you're
kind of there was this book
uh you read it on the podcast um and it
really this thing stuck with me because
i kind of had this
inkling of this concept but i never
could really arrive at it and embrace it
as much until i heard it where it's like
it taught basically i forget the exact
words but it said
like if you get sick that's kind of your
fault don't let your own thing
affect the team kind of thing it was
like old is one of these things
where it's kind of like if you get it
was it was kind of kind of raw because
sometimes right you just get sick you
get what's happening dysentery
or something you know it's like sure you
can take measures to try to avoid it but
sometimes it's unavoidable
this the book you're reading was like
still that's your bad don't let that
was that i forget but it was like man
your personal [ __ ] don't
don't even come over here with that
stuff you better keep keep moving
kind of a thing jack like damn try and
figure out what book that was we'll
we'll
go back to it yeah but it was uh it is
interesting so let's say we apply that
philosophy
boom we got some measures some
significant measures
that's a vitamin d three by the way
and also the cold war free immunity boom
also
the good news that i was about to
present we got
protein supplementation but we don't
need cupcakes anymore
it replaces the cupcakes and the
frosting you don't even need frosting
certified uh accepted
taste by pete roberts the sugar cube
addict which is a good thing in this
case as far as like
what do you call credentials yes i'm
saying so yes best tasting protein
on the market straight up in the world
straight up straight up
check it out also all this stuff if you
want to get it for
free shipped to your house you go to
jackofield.com if you subscribe to one
of these things you'll get it for free
shipping for free which is that's what
we're doing
to compete with other you know we're
talking about big guys little guys today
big companies little companies we've got
big companies out there
you know that are like shipping stuff
for free which is
good they have the capacity to do that
how do we compete with them
cool we figure out a way subscribe free
shipping
that works so there you go there's an
example real world example of the light
infantry mindset
going against the big heavy hitters out
there that's true that's a big deal of
free shipping
sometimes some of us you know when we
check out
we see that free shipping that's nice
mm-hmm
gotta admit it so yeah okay also
jiu-jitsu stuff because we're doing
jiu-jitsu now we're back
back in the game right back coronavirus
i remember that yeah you know those
things back in the day
but we're back doing jiu jitsu um so you
need some jiu-jitsu ghees rash guards
other equipment uh go to origin usa.com
that's where you can get them this is
all american-made stuff
yeah and just stuff for like wearing too
like things to cover your legs in
called pants the best pants ever you
know
delta jeans get factory jeans too if
you're living up north
we understand you're probably gonna get
the factory jeans they're heavier if
you're living down south or you're
living out the west coast
you're probably looking at the delta 68
genes
and boots you get boots yeah are they
doing that wallet
or is that just pete kind of flexing on
us he's doing the wallet
yeah there's a couple versions of the
wall there's like the real what are they
slim
yeah yeah minimal oh yeah whatever pete
called it concealed character
oh yeah right yeah he was up there all
cracked out on sugar cubes
could you carry wallet she probably was
well but like it is it is cool because
every time like because a wallet you
don't just automatically think well i
don't anyway but when you he'll bust it
out you can tell like you know he took
some pride in that one
you know so they put out some cool stuff
yeah no well pete takes
massive pride in the whole process from
designing it and then the functionality
of it and then the production of it yeah
because think about think about
something's going from his head from his
head
to people's hands passing through the
the company
being built by the factory like it's
awesome
so the whole everyone there everyone
there
when a wallet goes and when a pair of
boots goes out everybody there's pride
all over that stuff oh yeah
it's like you got to represent right you
can't just be throwing in some half
thought idea and be like here try this
and then show everybody it's like bro
we're not doing that kind of stuff we're
going all through yeah that's what we're
doing
we're not throwing something together
this is all in scenario
so is pete proud yeah is every person
that's on the line
creating this stuff proud hell yeah it's
freaking legit
makes sense also speaking of legit
dracula's store
this one equals freedom shirts and hats
and hoodies some rash guards on there
um some warrior kid stuff on there some
soap on there jocko soap trooper soap
killer soap antibacterial chart
black charcoal activated
satisfying soap all this stuff
um yeah so if you want to represent
while you're on this path
you know this is where you can you can
get your attire
your gear also we have a subscription
situation there too
shirts interesting designs creative
you're wearing one right now if you want
to go on youtube and look at the current
shirt that echo charles
is wearing unavailable by the way you
missed it a lot of people have it you
know they're representing
but here's the thing every time you're
learning and you're coming up with more
dope designs sure i try to keep a
standard quality
level or whatever either way it's fun um
yeah so
it's called the shirt locker so yeah man
sign up for that you know if you're
interested and
check out everything else on there
jackosdore.com if you like something
subscribe to the podcast
also check out the jocko unraveling
podcast with darryl cooper we've been
getting kind of crazy with those
getting nuts as they say but the
freaking awesome feedback we'll keep
knocking about grounded podcasts we
should talk to dean list we're getting
all those uh pretty soon
warrior kid podcast and you can also
join us
in the underground so so we have an
alternative platform that we are
we have created so that we have control
if contingencies unfold that we need to
execute an alternative platform
we're not doing it we hope to not do it
but things are strange in the world so
jockowunderground.com if you want to
help support the
the alternate world if needed you can
you can
pay eight dollars and eighteen cents a
month and we're doing like an additional
podcast where we talk about a
just really interesting stuff that's not
quite jackal podcast
material but it's jocko life material
alternative and amplifying informational
information yeah yeah and look if
we're if you just if you can't afford
that
no factor email assistance
jacounderground.com
we're just trying to make sure we're
taken care of and you're taking care of
should things start to go sideways we
also have a youtube channel
where i am the assistant director for
some awesome videos
and then echo puts some videos on there
too
unraveling is on there too by the way
all of them no but
they're they're getting rolled out as
well yeah got a new one up there
that's good to hear yeah those
unraveling podcasts
i'll be interested to read the comments
on those yeah so that's the thing
because those
really run the risk and they have
uh had like a you know youtube will flag
it because of the material
anytime you and daryl cooper start
talking about genocides and
all the you know the brutal realities
are going deep of history
and you know whatever it's like
youtube's like oh yeah pump your brakes
there
one time we were talking about something
and daryl was like you know this is
this particular thing and it's really
bad and it's just not appropriate
not what you want to hear on a podcast
and we got done i was like hey bro i
don't ever want to hear that again he's
like i'll never say it again
like that's what we're doing you know if
we don't address
if we don't address and inform people
about what
happens when things go sideways then
people don't realize how bad it is
that's what happens so yeah we're
getting flagged
and must be 18 or older you'd think that
we were putting out freaking
pornographic material we're not we're
talking about what communism does
we're talking about what authoritarian
governments can do
yeah yeah it is it never got
you know deep into history in high
school and all this stuff or whatever
but
kind of the significance isn't going to
be no news to you obviously but
when you do present it in such an
interesting way or whatever
it's one of the many valuable things you
can get from it is like yeah you realize
how bad it was back then
at the same time by contrast you realize
oh today
isn't that bad even the bad stuff that
happens like man you kind of compare to
the whole
thing it starts to it starts to offer
this
this maybe more enlightened perspective
on things well yeah and it also
offers you
an understanding of why things are
happening and how things happen
because look just like leadership is a
is something that you can learn about
from the past so is everything else
and to sit here and think that we're in
a you totally
unique time and that nothing like this
has ever happened before and
it'll be different this time that's
freaking wrong
that's just wrong the the way that the
world works the way
human nature works doesn't change and
there might be different technology but
just like technology won't make the
difference
in light infantry battle technology will
not change
human nature it'll have influence over
it but we need to watch out for what we
need to watch out for
human nature inherently does the same
things over and over again
so let's be careful check out the
unraveling check out daryl cooper's
podcast martyr made
right now there's a lot of there's a
flare-up going on in the middle east
you want to get the background on that
you want to try and you want to get get
some understanding of what's going on in
the middle east
you don't know i'm going to tell you you
don't know
and i studied the middle east and the
conflicts in the middle east daryl
cooper's podcast martyrmaid is
is a doctorate in
what happened in the israeli-palestinian
scenario situation so check that thing
out if you can
um psychological warfare i made an album
with tracks and you can get it
on any mp3 platform there's no music
by the way just fyi flip side canvas if
you need something hang on your wall
we got dakota meyer my brother he's got
an awesome company
made in america flip side canvas stuff
to hang up on your wall got a bunch of
books final spin
starting to get some anticipation from
people
about final spin because let's face it
it's hard to understand what's happening
you're looking at it you're seeing some
words you're
hearing about the story you're kind of
wondering what the hell is this about so
that's coming
pre-order it now so that the publisher
actually makes enough
actually makes enough uh leadership
strategy and tactics field manual the
code the evaluation of protocol this one
was freedom
way of the warrior kid one two and three
mike and the dragons about faced by
hackworth extreme ownership dichotomy
leadership these are the books
i've written thus far just getting
warmed up
i have a leadership consultancy called
echelon front
and this is what we do what we do is
leadership that's what we do
that's the only thing we do that's the
only thing we do
is leadership big companies small
companies
that's what we do all day long every day
if you have
any problems inside your organization i
can tell you right now
they are leadership problems
and the way you solve those problems is
through leadership go to
echelonfront.com if you want to work
with the echelon front team also we have
online training
we just put up 12 new courses where we
go through each chapter of extreme
ownership
and break down in a granular level
how to implement these these principles
in what you're doing
so check out efonline.com we have the
muster
it's live live event we didn't do any in
2020 because of miss rona
but we're executing may 25th and 26th we
got some seats left right now in orlando
get on it phoenix
is next august 17th and 18th that's
going to be a hot one
las vegas october 28th and 29th go to
extreme ownership.com
look we sell out so if you want to come
try and get there quick
also ef battlefield we do battlefield
walks i'll let you know when the next
one of those is taking place and also if
you want to help service members active
and retired
you want to help their families you want
to help gold star families then you can
check out a gold star
mom mark lee's mom mama lee she has a
charity organization
and if you want to donate or you want to
get involved go to america's
mightywarriors.org and if you want more
of my
obstinate opinions or you need more of
echo's incalculable comments
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter
on instagram or as echo calls it
the gram or on that facebook
echo's at aqua charles and i am at jocko
willink
and thanks to all the folks out there in
uniform right now
with a special shout out to all the
light infantry
thank you for making the sacrifices that
you make to protect us and the same goes
to those that wear the uniform
here on the home front talking about our
police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service
and all first responders thank you for
your sacrifices
to protect us here at home
and everyone else out there you might
not be
a light infantry soldier or leader but
you can certainly
adopt the attitude of the light infantry
the offensive mindset the initiative the
total self-reliance
the flexibility the improvisation the
discipline
the trust the confidence and a never
say die approach to problems
and if you go at life like that you are
going
to win so go out there
and get after it and until next time
zekko and jocko
you